we are now considering the motion of a
rigid body and we'd like to talk about
kinetic energy of rotation and
properties of that rigid body let's
consider a rigid body and let's say that
our rigid body is rotating about an axis
passing through a point s if we look
overhead in our rigid body then what
we're going to do is introduce a
coordinate system so this is our
overhead view and suppose that we have a
small element of our rigid body here
which I'm going to write as Delta M J
and that's a distance R J from the
center our rigid body has an angle theta
and what we like to do is describe a
coordinate system R hat theta hat and K
hat pointing like that
now with this rigid body that's rotating
we described the angular velocity as the
rate that the angle is changing with
respect to K hat and so we can draw the
vector Omega and this establishes our
coordinate system for one for our rigid
body and a small element of mass Delta M
J now what we'd like to consider is what
does this mass element do imagine that
it's over there because every point in
the rigid body has the same angular
velocity this object is going in a
circle with angular velocity Omega
recall that Omega is perpendicular to
the plane of motion but the object
itself has a velocity which I'm going to
write VJ and that velocity vector EJ is
in the tangential direction and it's
related to the Z component of our
angular velocity by the following
relationship it's how far we are from
the center point s times the Z component
of the angular velocity and it's
pointing in the tangential direction so
remember that Omega Z is equal to D
theta DT and this describes our
coordinate system for the rigid body now
what we'd like to discuss is the kinetic
energy and the way we're going to
consider
kinetic energy is we're gonna sum up the
rotational kinetic energy of every
single mass element so we begin by
writing K J rotational and we know that
that is just 1/2 times the mass element
times the velocity of that element
squared now we can use our relationship
for the tangential velocity element
related to the angular velocity and we
have 1/2 Delta M J RJ squared times
Omega Z squared now keep in mind that
Omega Z is the same for every single
mass element but the distance the mass
element are all different by RJ so the
total rotational kinetic energy is the
sum over J from 1 to N of let's put the
1/2 outside times Delta M j rj squared
now again recall that every element has
the same Omega Z so I can write
parenthesis Omega Z squared and that's
our rotational kinetic energy now what
we want to do now is look at the limit
as our Delta M J becomes very small
because we have a continuous body and
we'll write a definition which is going
to be the moment of inertia passing
through this point s about the axis
passing through s is equal to the limit
as Delta M J goes to 0 or n goes to
infinity of this sum Delta M J our J
squared J goes from 1 to N now because
this is a limit for the continuous body
will define it as the integral over the
body of a small mass element DM that's a
distance R squared now here what is the
meaning of the R well for our continuous
body here if we call this DM and we
define the distance from s to the body R
and now I'm going to just put a little
in here it's the distance from s the
axis we're calculating about to where
the body is DM so I'll write s DM and
this is what we call the moment of
inertia of a continuous body now again
what's very important to realize it's a
moment about a particular axis so this
is about an axis passing perpendicular
to the plane of rotation and through s
the point s so it's an axis that's
passing perpendicular to the plane of
rotation passing through the point s and
this is what we call the moment of
inertia of a body now we'll see that
there's the moment can be expressed in
terms of our other physical quantities
as of course develops you'll see two or
three more rental relations for moment
of inertia but what we'd like to do now
is summarize our results that the
kinetic energy of rotation is one-half
for rotation about this axis I'm just
going to indicate passing through s of
is times Omega Z squared now keep in
mind because Omega Z is a component it
can be positive 0 or negative but the
square is always a positive definite
quantity and that's our kinetic energy
of rotation let's contrast that with our
translational kinetic energy and we
remember there that was one-half times
the total mass of the object times V
squared cm where we're looking at all of
the object at the center of mass and
this is the total mass of the object